the team that brought you walls in
grumman now bring their first
full-length animated feature chicken run
this is a movie all the critics went
nuts for it was well written it was well
animated it was different it had a
unique story and it's another one
honestly I think just sort of falls into
the ok pile but that's not bad it's just
okay why well let's take a look on the
chicken farm in England one little hen
tries as hard as she can to escape
everyday but is constantly caught and
thrown back in things get more dangerous
though when the owner of the chicken
farm decides that she wants to start
making pies out of the chickens so the
hens had to make it out before the
machine that makes the pies is fully put
together their answer comes in the form
of a rooster played by Mel Gibson he
claims that he flew into the pen and
that he can teach the chickens how to
fly as well the only downside is his
wing is broken so he can't teach him
right away but he spends their time
trying to verbally show them how to do
it but the clock is ticking away as they
get closer and closer to pi day it's a
race to see if they can get out ala
Great Escape style before the owner can
turn him into mincemeat it was really
great seeing this animation team finally
do a full-length motion picture and
showing that they can pull it off and
still have it be very entertaining its
comedy is a little different from say
something like wallace and gromit which
was a little bit more quiet at times
this one is constant dialogue and
constant visual jokes modern Ascenta has
soared the same feel as walden from a
des it's not always trying to make you
laugh every second it'll take time just
to have a character breathe and talk
about however they're feeling a lot of
people say there was a ton of grown-up
jokes but really I didn't see them until
maybe near the end
I guess the only main problem I have
with it is that the story is a touch too
predictable I mean once again we're
gonna have the liar revealed backstory
it's not gonna be just brushed over
either it's gonna take up a good chunk
of the third act with the characters
moping and doping and oh Jesus have gone
on and on about this I'm not gonna
prattle anymore let's just say it's
boring and I don't think the jokes are
quite strong enough to make up for such
a lackluster part of the movie but like
I said before I still think it holds up
as being okay it is still very creative
it's got some memorable characters it
does have some good lines stop-motion
animation is always great to see I mean
this team always does a wonderful job
it's bright it's colorful it's mostly
upbeat it's very imaginative at times
and it has one or two bits for adults -
had it not gone for the liar revealed
story arc and maybe thought a little bit
more out of the box I would have liked
it a lot more but I still think it's a
decent flick it's got just enough for
kids and just enough for adults I think
it's worth at least